how does one who is single and has been
single for a while
and has been very good at being single
for a while
how does that person who is now
especially and this is gonna sound like
i'm talking about you but i'm talking
about a lot of friends right now that we
have that are
late 30s early 40s
they don't need to get married they're
doing great they're making money
but they're getting to a point where
they're sitting there saying i wouldn't
mind having a kid right i wouldn't mind
having a family honestly i'm so sick of
it the number that used to matter when
you would brag to your friends you know
the number like oh i've been with this
many others
no one cares anymore like who cares
about what the number is anymore at this
point it mattered in 20s it doesn't
matter in your 40s
what what challenges is that 40 year old
male gonna face to go from being fully
free
for many many years to all of a sudden
decide to commit to one person and build
a family what challenge is that guy
going to face
i have
my friend john from modern life dating
is probably a pretty good example of
this as well
is once you get to that point once you
get to like 36 37 years old and let's
just say you've been on your game you
have maximized your potential uh as you
know your value as a guy
uh there will come a point where you
have um
let's just say solve the mystery of
women you've solved the mystery of money
you've solved the mystery of whatever it
is that sort of has been your obsession
for as long as it has been and now it
seems kind of like uh like old old news
to you and what's the next challenge
what's what's next what's the next goal
and i
i have said this as well is that i think
that again that men and women are innate
compliments we're better together than
we are apart and i think that at some
stage men are going to say you know what
i would rather have the quality than the
quantity
but those guys don't get to that stage
unless they kind of go through the idea
that they either had the cos the
quantity or that they could have had the
quantity
most men like i said when the average
age of marriage for men is
the ones that are getting married is
like 29 years old that also coincides
right at that epiphany phase that i was
just talking to you guys about so when
that guy's 29 years old and he's not
quite reached his peak potential when he
gets to 36 37 years old and he's already
committed to a woman who was like 20
years you know 28 years old back in the
day he might be thinking well damn i
didn't know i was going to be this hot i
didn't know i was going to have this
much money i didn't know i was going to
be at this status and that's why you get
things like the midlife crisis at that
point and so it's not so much a midlife
crisis as it is oh damn i now realize my
own potential and uh now i'm having
second thoughts or now i'm like you know
i'm i'm going to go buy a sports car so
i'll relive my my youth
that's really sort of where that comes
from but when those guys are
are not committed and they get to 230
that's one scenario the other scenario
is the one you just said is when they
get to be 36 37 years old maybe 38 years
old pushing 40 and they go you know what
i'm done with this i really kind of want
to want to log out and i want to you
know have something that's a little more
permanent they'll ask me they'll say
rolo i don't want to get with one of
these girls i'm fresh and fit who's like
18 22 years old because they seem kind
of really you know flighty and not
somebody you want to start something
with but also i don't want to get with a
woman who's sort of like used up and is
really kind of full of herself an alpha
female at 33 years old who has sort of
built herself into that archetype
how do i solve my problem i tell them
you say you know you have to look for
certain you have to be a good judge of
character you've got to be able to if
you're reading my books if you've if you
if you're red pill aware if you're a
good judge of character if you maximize
your potential i've always said that the
the sweet spot is kind of somewhere
between like say 25 and 27 years old and
looking for a woman who uh who
understands like what her sexual market
value is versus what her personal value
is and those women do exist and i want
to point that out it's not like i think
a lot of people think that i think all
women are the same no or all men are the
same no i'm not saying that there are
commonalities that are that are
characteristic of men and women we have
our sort of innate differences of course
but when you're talking to like women in
different cultures in different
religions in different countries
wherever though those cultures are going
to be vastly different than they are
here in the united states because maybe
they haven't sort of been corrupted with
like you know feminism or whatever to
that point so you're looking at women in
like muslim like muslim majority
countries you're looking at latin latin
countries those
those women are going to be of a
different kind of like understanding of
like going forward this is what i'm what
i'm going to be about so there's a lot
of variables that give you a culture so
so so at that very this is what i took
from wood and and i'm curious what your
follow-up's going to be there is i'll
turn it over to you right after this so
to me based on what you just said this
is what i took away from it
culture and
uh
tradition
is something you ought to value at that
age you ought to look for that is that
kind of what you're saying you should at
least have a good understanding of what
how that person with male or female came
to
their certainly their belief sets but
also uh what is it that has acculturated
them into the personalities that they
have so definitely you know there's
environmental influences there's natural
innate influences and then there's
cultural influences as well what do you
think about that you know
you know split your h plus seven
plus seven
plus seven yeah
well let me tell you something about
like age-appropriateness it only works
in the female sense it doesn't work in
the male sense because we live in a
gynocentric social order that says well
you know uh was it uh
keanu reeves they when he was dating his
his uh i think she was like 46 and he's
like my age like 53 or 54 years old and
the woman he was dating at the time
looks like his mother looks like they
like she's got gray hair and everything
and women were just like yeah he's
dating somebody that's uh that's age
appropriate you look at leonardo
dicaprio none of his girlfriends have
been older than 25 years old and as soon
as they get to 26 he cycles them out and
gets another twenty three years
of milk exactly and so that's and and
you can there are actually online sites
that like track his his girlfriend's
ages across the so who's doing it right
who is leo doing it right or is is uh is
keanu doing it right is kendall still
with the lady i don't i don't know but
that was yeah that's the that's the the
gal right there i believe hugh jackman
is like yeah hugh jackman hugh jackman
is my age he's 53 and his wife is 66
years old what's uh
who is 54 and i believe he's 41 or 42.
lisa monet had it going on for and she
was with lenny kravitz
macron uh the
pm of france is the president prime
minister whatever yeah his wife is like
20 years older than him but we only have
we only have we only have a problem with
age appropriateness when it is a man
that is dating uh you know kind of too
young so what's too young half plus
seven is it ten years if you look at the
difference between say um
like uh lisa bonnet and and jason momoa
what's that about a 10-year difference
yeah well 13 years so if you've got a
guy who's 33 and he's dating a
20-year-old girl technically it's
illegal he could go ahead and do that
but we go oh my gosh he's robbing the
cradle right but if it's the other way
around oh she's a cougar
i don't think about it i just think is
it going to work
you know you you may you may be like oh
that's cool you know more and ashton
kutcher yeah that was that was a success
story
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you